AZA STEEL: My name's Aza,
I'm the CEO of GoGuardian.
We're an educational
security startup,
and I'm going to be talking
about how to find the best
engineers, and how
to attract them
to join your awesome company.
I'm going to think of the
talent acquisition process
as you might think of
deal stages in a CRM.
And so our deal stages are
going to be lead, to contact,
to process, to close.
So before you even
start thinking about
that it's really important
to clarify in your head
who you're looking
for, and what you're
looking for in an engineer.
So chances are you
probably want someone
that's smarter than you.
You might want someone that has
particular language experience,
or experience building
particular types
of applications, whether
that be mobile or web.
So clarify that for
yourself because that's
going to be really
helpful in making sure
that you find the right person.
There's basically
two types of ways
that you can go after a lead.
You're going to either
find a passive way,
or it's going to
be an active way.
So in terms of passive
ways, you're basically
putting something out there.
You're saying, hey I'm looking
for this type of talent.
And then you may get some bites.
What I've found, those bites
are usually less talented, hard
to find candidates,
than the ones
that you can find if you
find more active methods
and you're really
going after them.
You're being proactive
and you're saying,
hey I see this person, I see
this is their qualifications,
and I'm going to get
them for my startup.
Some of the more
passive ways that
have worked for
us in the past are
things like posting to Hacker
News which is a website.
Something that's worked for me
is posting on Facebook saying,
hey, this is what I'm
looking for in a candidate.
Does anyone know anyone?
Because then you're using
your social networking
and you're using your friends'
social network to find someone.
The more active ways
that I'm really a fan of,
there's a website called
AngelList-- it's angel.co--
and there's a whole
recruiting section where
you can go through all
these people's profiles
and do keyword searches
for particular skills
that you're looking for.
So let's say you're looking
for a Node.js engineer.
You can do a search for
Node.js and a search for people
that are looking in
your area for jobs,
or people that have jobs
and Node.js in your area
and go about it that way.
Then you need to think
about-- so you figured out
how to get in touch
with this person.
You need to think about what
your message is going to be
and how it's going to
be compelling to them,
so it's helpful to think about
it from their perspective.
They're an engineer, they're
making a great salary,
they have these great benefits,
but what don't they have?
And what they don't have is
probably a potential for really
tangible positive impact.
They might not have a lot of
autonomy in their job setting.
They might not
have an opportunity
for a significant financial
upside, i.e., equity
if there's an exit, or
an IPO or something.
So you want to play to your
strengths and their more
traditional current
businesses' weaknesses.
To me, the most
important thing here
is that you actually think
about them as people.
And you need to-- so when I
start writing an email to them,
I won't say hi name,
I'll say hi John,
so I can start thinking about
this actual person in my head
that I'm trying to convince
to join my company.
And so I like to go for the most
personable methods possible.
So if you can find
their phone number,
and you can just pick up
the phone and call them,
I've had tremendous
success with doing that.
Because you're usually
both so confused
that you're on the
phone with each other,
that it just kind of works and
you establish a connection,
and then you talk about
why they would be great
added benefit to your team
and then it goes from there.
If you can't get their phone
or they aren't answering
their phone, then I would
say a personal email
is the next best.
So an email I've
sent in the past
is like, hey, we need an
awesome Node.js engineer.
So I find some
people on AngelList
that have great
Node.js experience,
I mention some of that
experience in the email
and say, hey, it looks like
you did some really cool stuff
building these web apps.
And say what we're
looking for is someone
to build these highly
scalable node applications,
and this is why
you fit the bill,
and this is the company
that you'll be joining in,
why it's an awesome company
and the amazing traction
that we've had and
why this is something
that they're going to want
to really get on board with.
A lot of times people go wrong
because they don't actually
have an action item at
the end of the email.
There's no call to action,
and so it's really important
that you have a call to action.
And it can either
be an email reply,
or I really like
suggesting a time
to touch base on the phone.
So that makes sure that
you ask them a question,
there's kind of an expectation
that they're going to reply--
or you hope that
they're going to reply--
and then you can touch
base on the phone.
And that's really the
goal, because that's going
to bring it to the next level.
So now that you've
verified them on paper,
and you've talk to them
and verified that there's
at least some level
of interest, you
need to make sure that they
can actually do the job.
And chances are you're going
to be looking for someone
that has a certain
level of experience
and you need to verify that.
And you need to probably
either have them do a coding
challenge, or have them
do a take-home coding
challenge, where they
can dive into a project
and you can see
some of their work.
And if you're not
really someone that
should be reviewing
their code, make sure
that you have a
friend look at it
or have a friend hop on
a phone call with them,
and talk about some
of the technical areas
that you want to make sure
that they have expertise in.
Because people can be fairly
good at convincing you on paper
that they have certain
aptitudes and skills,
and you want to make
sure that they actually
have the goods to back it up.
So now to actually
get them on your team,
it's really important
to think about them
as a whole person, and
what about your job
is going to be really
compelling to them
and where they want
to be in their future,
and how you can play a part
in getting them to that place.
You're talking to top engineers.
Some of these top engineers
are going to say no,
and it's really important
that you engage with them
and figure out why they said no.
And it's important
for two reasons.
One, a lot of the
time, by understanding
that, you can actually
get them back on your side
and maybe it was a, hey,
this is just bad timing
and you can engage them
on a contract basis
until it's better timing,
or something like that.
Two, you need to
refine your process,
and the only way you
can refine your process
is by understanding
what isn't working,
and by talking to them
about what you could perhaps
have done better.
These strategies
have essentially
allowed me to build this, from
what was around a year ago, me
sleeping on my friend's
couch trying to figure out
how to grow this idea into a
20-person organization, that's
growing incredibly
fast, and we're
on something like 800,000
Chrome books in education,
and protecting students
in their online activity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]